it is Sunday night approximately 11 p.m  it is cheat mail Sunday for all of us  around the world certainly for me here  and the reason why this is history in  the making is because this is the very  first time that I have ever  tried  and In and Out Burger  or In-N-Out fries or anything from in  and out for that matter now I've picked  up some In-N-Out Burger before through  the drive through a few times for some  buddies of mine I've never tried it so  this is a first uh let's see I have two  double doubles  they're called double doubles loaded  with lettuce tomato onion pickles and  cheese of course we've got fries here  get this  the fries are good